-Paris!
-Hello.
What's up, New York?!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
The memoir's out tomorrow.
I want to get to this.
I want to talk about
the last time
you were on our show,
which I'm so psyched
every time you come on.
It's always great.
Last time,
do you remember what happened?
-Yes.
You -- commercial came,
and someone ran out.
Was it your mom?
-Yes.
-Your mom ran out and goes,
"Paris, you're wearing
two different shoes."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-During the whole interview.
And you didn't know.
I didn't know.
No one said anything.
But here's the picture of you
before -- before you changed.
This is during
one of our interviews.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I have a close-up
of just the shoes there,
just so we know.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know how I, like,
didn't notice that,
because one is, like,
all crystallized
and one is, like, nude.
-Did anyone think
that you were doing this
on purpose,
like it's a style choice?
-They did.
People were like,
"Who is the designer?
That's so cool."
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
That's so good.
But your mom came out
and straightened it out.
And so, you changed shoes.
But I just wanted
to remind that.
That made me laugh.
[ Laughter ]
-Only me.
-Only you.
This is the greatest thing
to ever happen to you
right here, pal.
You became a mom.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He is such an angel.
-How is he?
-He's the best.
He's the cutest, sweetest.
I'm just so obsessed with him.
My heart feels
like it's gonna explode.
-Really?
-Mm-hmm.
-And do you just stare at him
when he --
-Stare at him.
-Right?
-Yes.
-That's all you do.
You just go, "Oh, my God.
You're a perfect baby."
-It's the best.
-It's the best thing.
And mom, Kathy,
is loving being grandma?
-Yes.
-Yeah, I could just imagine.
-Obsessed. Just showing up
all the time, unannounced.
-Unannounced, yeah.
-She's, like, in there.
I'm like, "Mom,
when did you get here?"
She's like,
"Oh, I've been here for hours."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just waiting for you
to -- yeah, I got to wait
for the baby to wake up.
Now -- you being a D.J.,
I'm assuming you have
a good playlist for the baby.
-Yes, of course.
-You do?
-Mm-hmm.
-What is baby into now?
-Well, I actually sang his
favorite lullaby is my song
"Stars are Blind."
-Really?
-Mm-hmm, yes.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
He has good taste in music.
-Yeah.
By the way,
you were great with Miley.
-Thank you.
-That was fantastic.
-I love her so much.
She's so cool.
-No, you can't beat Miley Cyrus.
But that was such a surprise.
I had no idea
you were gonna come out
and rock it out and do "Stars."
She's a fan of the song?
-Yes.
-I love her.
-Dude, you guys together.
Yeah.
-She is epic.
-That was awesome.
Let's talk about --
you have a memoir.
It's out tomorrow.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-When did you realize that you
were ready to write a memoir?
Was it the doc?
-Definitely the documentary.
That was the first time
that I actually got real
and started just thinking about
so many things
I'd went through in my life.
-Yeah.
-And it was just time,
I feel that, to tell my truth.
-Yeah.
It's -- It gets --
the struggle story's in there,
and it gets dark
at certain points.
But there's funnier,
lighter moments
and things in here that I --
that I never knew about you.
But I think this is,
for one example,
you like to do
prank phone calls?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know this about you.
You have a separate phone
just for pranking people?
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, how did you do it?
And where did you learn
to prank phone call?
Was it something you did
in high school?
-My mom taught me.
[ Laughter ]
-Your mom pranks people?
-She's the queen of prank calls.
She is so good at it.
-Really?
-Yes.
-And how do you all react?
Do you hear on the other line,
or pick up when she calls,
or speaker phone?
-We do it at her house, like,
usually during parties,
like, at the end.
Like, we'll all get together
in the room and just, like,
have a prank-calling
after-party.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-And when you do it,
do you change your voice at all?
-"Yes, my name is Phyllis,
and I like to smoke the cigs,
and I would love to move into
your apartment, darling."
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just --
"I like to smoke the cigs."
-Yes, I don't know.
Someone --
-Why not do that?
I love learning that stuff,
because it's funny, it's light.
But you always
had a good sense of humor.
And, also, your business brain
is phenomenal...
-Thank you.
-...to learn about.
And you learn about this.
I also will say,
it does get very dark,
for people that
don't know you, know you.
-Yeah.
-You kind of are in shock,
and you go like, "Wow.
I didn't realize
you went through this."
And I'm happy
that you're telling your story.
But this is -- a lot of stuff
happened to you as a teenager.
And you've actually taken it
to -- to -- to Congress.
-Yeah. We've changed laws
in eight states so far
and all the way in Ireland.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Yes.
And now we're going back to D.C.
in April to introduce
our new bill
to make this federal.
-Come on. This is --
You are so fascinating.
Congrats on this.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on this,
and congrats on this, too.
-Yes.
-I mean, come on.
That's -- it's really
the best thing ever.
-My two babies.
-Paris Hilton, everybody!
"Paris: The Memoir"
is out tomorrow.
Pick it up online,
go to Barnes & Noble,
wherever books are sold.
We'll be right back
with Collin Morikawa.
Stick around, everybody.